so how are you making 4 grand a month
from it when you don't own it uh yes so
we pay the rent and then we let it as
Airbnb and all these other platforms how
much do you pay to the landlord uh 3 and
a half thousand three and a half Grand
yeah three and a half Grand and you make
four grand profit yeah why don't they
just rent it out themselves it's just
too much hassle and they've moved off
abroad so they're not really too fast
how do they feel knowing that you're
making so much profit from their house
they're completely fine with it they
don't know how much we're making but
they're fine with it they just want the
circle of they get their money I get my
money and just repeat sort of things